[Music]
hello, I'm yolanda azcúnaga customer
engineer at google cloud and today I wanted to
talk to you about daya love love the
tool that allows you to build
voice and text virtual assistants from
google d'angelo flow allows us to
build
rich and natural conversational interfaces in a simple way
dialogue  flow is responsible for helping us
throughout the life cycle of
building people from the conversation management part,
helping us with a
natural language understanding engine to the
integration part with the different
channels and with our own systems
to build responses  rich and
customized for the user himself, what
functionalities does aló flow provide us,
since a main functionality is to
give us speed of implementation, it
allows us to start building our
bot chats with very few example interactions,
that is, we will use
the locutions that our users are going
to  interact with the agent to
deliver new  Our model and we need
very few training examples to
start doing it, in addition to ayala flow, it
consists of 40 preconfigured agents that
can be used as a base to
build our own chat bots
so that if we want to build, for
example, an agent that is in charge of
managing tickets from  support we can
use the base model as a starting
point and customize it based on
our needs in this way
we can have a simple bot in
production in a few hours it
also helps us to achieve
more efficient interactions with
users these
language understanding capabilities  natural that
google has been working on them
for many years, it takes advantage of all this
intelligence that has been developed to
incorporate it into daya lovelock and
make interactions with
users much more natural, it also
has multiple
integration options to be able to incorporate your
systems into  your form assistant  because
when a user, for example, in the case
of a chat for a restaurant in which he
wants to make a table reservation, we can
integrate it with our
reservation systems through dialog flow to be able to monitor in real time
if there is a space in our
restaurant available and  give you an
answer and automatically generate the
reservation this can be done by calling
an end point that we have in our
own systems or also using
cloud functions cloud functions is a
service of google cloud platform of
computing server allows us to
execute codes without having to manage
any  server so that we can
build much more complex
responses our response with a crm or with the
reservation system or any other
system that we want, it is also very
important in all the management of the
attendees to monitor
them since we need to continuously
improve the  people to
better understand our users for it  da
ya la flor incorporates
analytical tools that allow us to see the use
that users are making of
our chat boot, last but not
least,
the ability that it gives us to maximize the
reach that our agent has is also fundamental, it is
possible to already count on it  lazy to develop
our chat bot once and
deploy it on the platform that
we want, either through the IP or
through one of the 14
single click integrations that allow us
simply by enabling the channel in
which we want to integrate what can be
yours facebook skype  google home a multitude
of integrations already pre-built in a
few simple steps to have our our
agent working on that platform in
addition to the flow consists of more than 14
languages supported 7 s o
houses for different progr
mming languages so that we can continue wo
king integrating our voice chat
ith  the language with which we
feel more comfortable now that
we already know a little  plus the
fundamental advantages that halo flow brings us
we are going to talk about the concepts
that we have to be very clear about
before starting to develop our chat the
first are the intentions the
intentions are the objectives in the
actions that we want to achieve with
our chat  but these intentions in the
case that we mentioned before about the
restaurant will be, for example, reserving
a table, checking the menu or checking
the opening time so that our
bold chat is able to understand that the
user, when activating
the locution, is referring to this
intention what we are going to do is
link each of the intentions with
a series of training
phrases these training phrases in the case
of table reservation could be I want to
reserve a table or there is space in the
restaurant once we have the
intentions and the
training phrases another fundamental concept
is entities entities is what
will allow us  r
Important information about the
user's interactions, either
because the user
is already giving us that information in the first request or
through questions that will come
later, in the case of table reservations,
we need to know which
restaurant and which day the user wants
make the reservation to be able to give him the
information, then either the
user is going to tell us that he wants to reserve a table
at the restaurant and tomorrow he will be giving us
all that information, those
entities that we have to extract, or
if he has not given us that information and
only  he said I want to reserve a table
we will have to ask him for these
values these entities can be of an op
n type for example a date where
we can take advantage of the entit
es already created by dialog for very
ommon cases such as numbers dates or count
ies and then there will be others that will be speci
ic  for our people, for
example, the name of the restaurants
here, we do not want  be an
open field but we want it to be a
closed number of options so that in
the event that the user tries to
reserve in a place
that is not part of our chain,
he will ask again and even give him
suggestions for the restaurants where he
can reserve all this  we achieve it by
generating entities another
fundamental concept to make the
conversation natural and fluid is to
work with contexts if we
talk to a person and want to
make a reservation if first we have
asked about the restaurant menu and
then we say I want to
reserve a table  in this restaurant it
will not ask us again what the
name of the restaurant is because we want
our chat bold to work in the same
way so we will play with the
contexts to transfer information
between the different intentions and that
the conversation is as natural as
possible and one  Once we have defined
all this conversation management, the
final step will be  To comply,
what we want is to reserve a table,
that is, we want to verify in our
systems if there is a free space and execute
a reservation and that table is blocked in
our system
and we will use the
dialog flow integrations with
external systems through a  instep where
we can make a call and make this
query about the availability of the table
and the subsequent reservation or with the
jones clauses as I mentioned
before with cloud functions you can
execute code without managing servers
within an editor that is integrated
into the console  daia lovelock and
we will also be able to consult data from the crm
data from any database and
integrate it all into a much
more complete response now that we are clear about
all these concepts if you think so we are
going to build our first
agent we will go to the dialog flow console
and we are going to create a new agent in this
dropdown we will explain in the
create new button  agent
the first thing we have to do is
give the people a name
we are going to call them from holland restaurant
and select the language we want
from our agent we can have more than
one language in this case we are going to
select Spanish as the default language
people  it is going to be linked to a project
that is an existing concept in google
cloud platform to group resources in
this case we are going to create a new one for
our agent we will give it create and
meanwhile we are going to see the
different components that we have in the
console you see that the  The first element that
tells us is the intention part, it is
those objectives that we want to
achieve with our chat.
We also have an area to manage our
entities and other areas that we are not going to
see in detail in this video to
connect with different databases and
make answers.  more complex by
connecting it with these cloud functions
our agent has already been created and
we are ready to create  For our first
intention, here you can see that we already have
two default intentions, one for in
the event of an error and
another to welcome,
we can modify them or use
the ones that are already created by default,
now we are going to create our own for
make this table reservation we will give it a
name
in this case table reservation and we are going to
start giving it these
training phrases we are not going to use
the contexts and events in the example but we are
simply going to start directly
from the phrases as users
normally request  reserve a table because
for example I want to make a reservation
I would like
a table for today
you see that there are several words that have been
put in different colors this is
because automatically giving the flow
tries to extract entities from the phrases
that we are giving it to
train in  In this case, as we
have not yet trained the model, many of
them are incorrect, so we are going to
eliminate the ones that  We are not interested,
we are going to delete them and we are going to be left
alone with the correct ones, for example for
today, yes, it is a date, it
has automatically taken an entity
created by default by the system, which is
6 dates, which will then allow us to
extract the dates  of the voices of
the users in I want to make a reservation,
two have been detected but in this case
we are not interested in any as we
train the model and mark the
entities that we want to extract,
this extraction will improve, so
we already have our example phase, the
next step is to define  the entities
that have not yet marked the model
we are going to save our intent and we are
going to go to entities we have seen that
we can use the date generated by
default by halo flow but in the list of
restaurants we are interested in creating
a closed list  with our names
we are going to create one called
restaurants and we are going to give it the
possible values then restaurant 1 resta
ante 2
this list could be much longer
with more complex architectures of the
entities so that, for example,
certain formats are maintained if we want
it to be a number of X digits
we can make it much more much more
complex in this example we are going to
stay with something very simple  which would be a
list with two values we will
ave our entity and we will return to ou
intent in ou
table reservation attempt we al
eady had the training phrases and we ha
e already seen that an en
ity has been automatically created for the date
e are going to say that this entity is manda
ory  that is to say, always ask
us for it and therefore if the user does not
indicate it in his request
we have to indicate how we
want people to ask for this value, for
example it can be on what date he wants to
reserve
we could give more than one example in this
case for  simplicity we are going to leave only
1 and now we are going to create a new
parameter for the restaurant and we are going
to link it with the people  e that we have just
created here is the list of all those
that are in the system by default and
those that we have created
we are going to give the value a name we are going to
tell it that it is a list that this will be
interesting if we integrate it into certain
platforms that  they show the lists so
that you only have to click and we are going to
tell them that it is mandatory so that they
ask us for the value
then we will say in which restaurant
in which restaurant as I was saying that it is
very interesting to give examples so that it
is the first the user does not tell us  A
restaurant in our chain gives you a
choice between restaurant 1 and 2 and thus
guide you in the conversation
now we have everything set up
we just need to give an answer as
we saw before we can make
very complex answers by integrating it with our
reservation systems and adding
everything  that we need as
additional information collected from a crm in this
case we are going to stick to something very
simple we are going to give a re  response
in plain text where we confirm the
reservation
then we are going to tell you your reservation in
we are going to tell you to tell us the name of the
restaurant
on the day by calling the parameters that
the user entered and entered has been
confirmed
we have the answer here and now we just
It remains to save our intent
here you see the intent is going to be saved and
automatically our agent is going to be
trained while our agent is being trained we are
going to see the fulfillment part you see
that here we have put a very
simple response but if we wanted to do some
integration it is so simple  how to go
here and we can use the embed
code editor in the console to
start working with more sophisticated integrations
our people have already been
trained and are ready to
use so if we go now we see
that in the right column of the
console itself we can start  to use
our people and to wish it
we go to greet him we say hello
automatically people give us  to the
welcome with that intent that is
created by default and we are going to ask him for a
table reservation we are going to tell him I would like
a table in this case for tomorrow
you see that he automatically asks me
what restaurant this is in because he has
detected that this expression corresponds
to  the intention is to reserve a table and is
trying to fill in the parameters and they
have already been able to know that for tomorrow,
although in the example we had put it
for today, it is equivalent to the date and
transform it into a value that we can
use for our reservation system,
but he has  seeing that we are missing
the restaurant and that is why he asks us if
we now put restaurant 4, which is not
a restaurant of our chain, he
asks us again here we could have
put that answer where he
suggests choose restaurant 1 restaurant
2 we
would choose restaurant one he already tells us
your reservation in restaurant 1 on March 27,
2019 has been confirmed
we already have our chat room ready if
we want now  integrating it in any of the
channels is as simple as going here and
enabling the integration if we are
talking about a website we would simply
click and we would have a demo ready to
interact with our chat bot in a
web model well now that we have seen
how to build our first chat  bot
we are going to see what the next
step would be once we have the production button chat
we are going to use the
monitoring and analysis tools in beverages to
continuously improve it these
tools are going to collect all the
voiceovers that users make with
our people  and they are going to tell us which ones have
been mapped to an intention and which ones have
not so that we can see if we have
to train our people with these
phrases or if there are topics that
users are asking us for information
and that we have not created an
intention, we also  it will also show
the flows that users follow
through our agent in the
different steps  from the conversation
in this demo we have seen how to create a
chat bot with dialog flow now I encourage you to
try it yourself in the url
you can access the console
thank you very much for your attention
i